airplane mode yo let's go baby whoa
okay let's go good enthusiasm
and who wants McDonald's too because I'm
getting McDonald's on the side why don't
we just get McDonald's let's just get
McDonald's we just had this conversation
oh my God no because I just want french
fries on the side yeah but now you're
young because if I get french fries I'm
gonna get the whole shebang I gotta get
the whole thing you didn't order it
[Laughter]
that's dancing we're gonna save this
video and put it on Instagram
Hey Joe what are we getting for lunch
McDonald's
there's McDonald's in Hawaii
you guys are ordering McDonald's on this
off the Record yeah what's up that's
hilarious JK order lunch we're oh we're
ordering oh it's because the camera's
already rolling here go go go three two
one
[Music]
welcome back we have a very very amazing
episode ahead of you of the careful boys
featuring today Kristen everybody
Kristen and you know what Chris has got
a great little story to share so
everybody grab your popcorn let's get
into it we're talking about murderers
everybody likes murderers these days I
know yeah you got his ax in your shirt
all right continue yeah so I know it's a
Hot Topic right now Dahmer Dumber you
guys want a hottie Mr so sexy why don't
you eat the sandwich I made you that's
my favorite part would you have dated
him in his youthful useful I mean I'm
not a man I don't think without knowing
that he was it bad just this look I mean
just off the looks yeah just from the
looks aside from looks if he was on
hinge would you swipe right or left yeah
I don't think I think I would find him
on grinder I don't think uh yeah I know
but like yeah but like for the sake of
the story yeah it's probably not
probably not my time okay
um yeah so Dharma really popping right
now with the Netflix show that just came
out
um we all know what he did
um but the crazy thing behind it is my
dad was a lieutenant for the Milwaukee
Police Department at the same time as
all this was going down
I just went down to Milwaukee because I
don't want yeah it's in
it's
important
I didn't really know the story before I
knew he was a serial killer as I'm
watching the show it seems really really
familiar to me and I'm like wait a
minute I think my dad told me this story
when I was really young I was probably
you know in a great story to tell for
her I was a young child yeah I know I
was in that grade school but my dad you
know he would come back from work he
would tell us these stories that would
happen when he was on he wouldn't
believe the confidential [ __ ] I'm about
to spell what a day
she's like nine years old how was work
Daddy it's career day at school you're
supposed to bring a parent in to talk
about their job your dad goes in talking
about Dahmer right so there's this guy
killed a lot of people like ladies you
don't have anything to worry about you
boys watch out little boys
um yeah so I'm watching the show in it
like I recognize this
um and my dad used to tell a story so I
was just in Wisconsin a couple weeks ago
and I realized that my dad had told me
the Dahmer story before all of this came
out because he was a part of it so I was
like Hey Dad I need you to Spill the tea
um he hadn't seen the show but I was
like tell me what you know about it um
because I want to figure out like how
they perceived it and yeah so he was the
lieutenant at the time he wasn't
directly on the case um but his friends
were like some of his buddies were the
two guys
um that like let the one kid go
and they were part of that so the story
behind that that they didn't share on
the media the reason because the police
department back then and you know now
how they perceived it they got a lot of
backlash on it like you know you could
have prevented this all these cases but
apparently at that moment the police
department was completely flooded the
crime was so so bad like he would be
getting calls Non-Stop and their
protocol was if there's something
serious going on you take that
um so that's why the cops kind of let
that go because they were just getting
calls left and right
um but yeah my dad he actually saw the
photos
um the Polaroids that Dahmer had whoa
yeah he saw them because um he was
helping investigate all of it
um the three photos that he specifically
remembers head in the freezer he's seen
that photo himself that's crazy that's a
long photo yeah it's nasty
um another one that he saw was I don't
think they showed this in the show but
um a body completely skinned in a
bathtub there's a Polaroid of that wow
and then the third one he vividly
remembers is there were two hands
chopped off
um and a penis in between that was
chopped off and he like put it
artistically like in between like a
little butterfly the two hands
um and there's a Polaroid of that so oh
really really crazy my dad saw all those
Polaroids
um another part of it
um he was talking because one of his
friends was the guy that was the
investigator
um one of his friends was the guy that
was the investigator so talk to Dharma
you know got all the details and like
they showed in the show Dahmer was
completely calm and explained everything
that was going on but one thing for
protocol that they asked them is have
you ever experienced anything yourself
have you ever been a victim and Dahmer
actually said that you know he was doing
this stuff he would drug the guys there
was one night that um he drank too much
crazy crazy alcoholic
um and he blacked out and he woke up and
he was tied by his hands and his feet
and some weirdo that he was trying to do
stuff too was doing it in return and he
was like I I do this to other people and
really really graphic
um I guess he took like a Candlestick
and it was like shoving it up his ass
like Dahmer and like doing weird weird
stuff to him and then ended up letting
him go
um thought he was gonna get killed but
he was telling the police department
like I know I've done some bad things
but there's other really really bad
people in this city so he also had been
a victim himself
um yeah I don't know he was just
directly involved with all of it I
wonder how true that is like there's
other serial killers and then they're
all just like
yeah they're bad well Dahmer can't
really talk though we did a collab
for post
yeah damn dude I don't know it's just
crazy that he was directly involved in
how big of a case that was at the time
you know Milwaukee's A Bad City there's
a lot of crime that goes on but
um that was one of their only serial
killers and
um you know he's directly involved with
all of it so I think that's pretty cool
shut up my dad shout outs to cops out
there too man because they whatever
crime scene they walk up on
it's just crazy [ __ ] you know like you
can you can't predict what's gonna
happen yeah you could open a door in
someone's like head blown like our buddy
he's like he he he heard like a shooting
call and then he had to go through and
investigate and when you opened up the
door someone just blew their brains out
and they'll splattered all up against
the wall and he's all like that's the
first thing he saw and it's like that's
like every day like you see crazy stuff
and I'm just like man after a while no
wonder they get desensitized and humor
seems to be the common thing for like
First Responders whether it's like cops
or like trauma nurses or or emergency
like rooms like
after a while you get it because it's
like that's the only way they can kind
of cope they just make fun of everything
and I'm like yeah does your dad have a
good sense of humor about this type yeah
he has like pretty dark jokes yeah yeah
I definitely have my dad's comedy um but
oh yeah that's right for sure for sure
super sick in the head let's go
I love the murder stuff but um
yeah there's another story so I not only
my dad was a cop um but my uncle was as
well it's kind of like a little family
thing oh that's cool and
um when my uncle when they're together
do they have like a smirk because only
they understand certain things so they
have like a common understanding no one
else you mean like [ __ ] falling off the
back of the truck on the way home from
military no no no I'm talking about just
you know we protect the city yeah
absolutely they were on different
departments um but my uncle when he was
first starting out um he got called the
scene like a burglary like some crime
going on and um he showed up to the
apartment
um there was a house or something he
knocks on the door someone answers and
was like oh yeah he ran out the back
door and then my uncle went to
investigate and the guy ran that was the
guy like oh my doing some [ __ ] like some
Three Stooges so he got away with that
that also means probably he got like
[ __ ] for it at the department afterwards
for like a long time huh [ __ ] the new
guy just letting people go there's this
crazy thing
um it's happening currently in Milwaukee
my dad's not on the department anymore
but is he retired yeah he's retired he
did like 20 years like 30 years or
something yeah he did a good amount of
time um he retired early he won like
some lawsuit there was some like stuff
going on in the police department I
don't really know how that worked out
but nice exit yeah now his new wife owns
a security company so like you know he
really likes it he's helping build it
kind of makes him feel like a cop again
that sound great but like
you're a loser very smart on the
business side but like he still likes
doing that kind of stuff
um but right now in Milwaukee
um you guys should do a story on this
sometime there's these we're doing it
right now talk about it okay there's
this group called The Kia boys have you
heard about it oh wait they're the ones
that yeah they Jack all the kios yeah
why kios because it's easy to steal
they're easy to Jack but it's not just
like gang members they're like 14 to 18
year old kids doing it so that um if
they're under the age of 18 they're not
going to jail they're just getting like
a little don't don't steal the cars but
that's true they're stealing all these
Kias and they're driving recklessly
crashing them they're not even using
them I didn't even know Kia's existed
anymore like I don't even see him on the
road they just deleted all kios is it
because they all just send Kias to like
Milwaukee dude I see Keys all the time
there's a bunch of them now yeah there's
some of the parking lots Joe just came
back to Earth do they do they even have
a Kia lot though like I haven't seen any
Kia dealerships there's yeah there's
cases that all-car dealership oh you
know what might be because they
rebranded a little bit and they changed
the logo
they disappeared but they're coming up
pretty big Cheetos are dope and now
they're getting oh is it because their
logo looks like that KK yes oh that's
the one yeah it looks like blades it
looks like little race they look cool
yeah they got some actual adult like
SUVs that's why you don't see them now
because you expect to see a dorky thing
but they yeah but they're getting stolen
I was just home a couple weeks ago my
dad one of their work cars
um got busted into and these guys were
trying to steal it
um I think it was Ikea yeah I mean
they're doing other cars too but they're
known as key boys but
um he let me borrow his car to drive
places but they have these things where
you lock the wheel so every time I would
park I thought yeah old school I I would
feel super sketchy I had to like put
this thing on the wheel and like take
the keys is it red
well I'm not used to that I got one
right now you don't see them that much
go get it it's gonna take you like 12
minutes to go find it then we're gonna
be in a new video already
classic job
because I got one right now literally
he's gonna be back in the next we're
gonna go look for 20 minutes he goes I
left it in Hawaii why is it not on the
steering wheel
we should do an entire JK Adventure Time
oh he's getting his keys okay wait step
down he's really proud of this so the
club the club was a it was a big 90s
thing to happen yeah oh too like it was
on all the infomercials like call this
now you get like one or two more yeah
Avi was also dope to know that you had
that in your car kind of like a girl you
talking about one of these you talking
about oh yeah yeah he's talking about
one of these
this is how you know the age is so
different dark like we grew up using
these like why you still have it because
you need the first car because you still
use it cars still have steering wheels
because old cars you can still steal in
like the old ways very easily and you
got to protect the deal you better put
that back on your [ __ ] car dude
there's gonna be gone
your car's a hot come on I left that
unlocked right now too
there's no time is this what you're
talking about yeah exactly so yeah you
stick down on the steering wheel and it
keeps it from like turning yeah yeah it
just like did you know there's an
infomercial that teaches you how to
dismantle it an infomer
infomercial because they're trying to
sell a new product so instead of the
club they have the pedal one and they
said see the reason why the club doesn't
work all you need is a saw so they got a
saw you saw the steering wheel and the
steering wheel just bends and so you
just pull the club out yeah because the
steering was easy to [ __ ] cut but the
pedal the pedal one it locks in place
and you can't cut the pedals off if you
need it to drive yeah but if they ruined
the steering wheel that devalues the
classic status of my truck
tell them Joe let them know I feel like
robbers are gonna be like nah dude we're
trying to steal this in pristine
condition especially with a torso
I was I was wondering when I would hear
someone talk about the club like it's an
artifact yeah that was it yeah I'm like
this thing this rod thing yeah I never
heard about that it's tight wait so um
when you when you made the connection
that like your your dad was a part of
this stuff was it like oh [ __ ] that's
Dahmer like how did you know that that
was him well I knew because I remember
him telling me a story about Polaroids
and a head in the freezer oh so as soon
as that came pretty classic I was like
yo you probably knew about it like
months before anybody else like publicly
yeah and I'm like in first grade and
he's like okay good night sweetie yeah I
also wonder if like at that time in the
Departments like maybe your dad's not
working on the case but when you get
something so [ __ ] wild like Polaroids
of that yeah it's like and let me see
those photos yeah but he was like you
know what I mean so he was like higher
status Lieutenant was dealing with all
that stuff the detectivizing like you
know the detective visors are doing that
and the supervisors of the supervisors
are looking at what the detective Eisen
guys do and then they they go oh all
right good job
good job good work Johnson really good
uh yeah good detective work yeah when
you lieuten in his eyes right you you
typically just supervise that's what the
lieutenant does I mean if you have
access to the evidence Chambers like
wouldn't you just kind of like whoa whoa
damn look at that [ __ ] about a bad day
you get full access that's kind of cool
I'm sure people would like I'd be
curious there's no way even if it's
[ __ ] grotesque or something even if
it's like Yo dude we got like this
[ __ ] this whether it's drugs this
giant ass [ __ ] pound of money or a
bunch of money to to murder whatever
like I'd be curious that's curious
people like in hospitals do the same
thing they're like yo check out this
extra [ __ ] huge pickles in this guy
his ass you know that's fun though that
is funny everywhere they do that I
remember even in second grade like you
forget your sweater so you go to lost
and found after you find her [ __ ] you're
like what else is it yeah
look at this has your dad seen the
document oh not the documentary has he
seen the show no he hasn't watched it
yet you know there's like a bunch of
them has he ever seen any at any point
I'm curious to see if he were to watch
the show and I'm curious to see if he
would like point out anything that would
be like they should have interviewed him
there's very few people that could watch
Dahmer and just go that didn't happen
yeah
to be one of those people yeah when he
talks about it is it like a
like he remembers the Glory Days or is
he like perturbed by it and doesn't want
to bring it up because it was so dark no
he'll definitely talk about it yay
that's [ __ ] wild dude just to be a
part of like one of the most notorious
like [ __ ] serial killers of all time
do you think he would say that's the
worst thing he's seen on the force like
when he was active
um I mean he's definitely seen in person
stuff because that that was just
photographs but I mean as a cop you see
a lot of crazy things I mean you show up
on a scene like
you know you you know what the but you
know there's like there's like a
Darkness right like if I were to go into
a room and I saw like uh hypothetically
the gore of like a dismembered body and
that was like a yeah but like a one in
one case versus like the gore of a
dismembered body knowing that this was a
pattern of like 17 other victims and you
know what I mean like there's a mental
darkness that goes on yeah I feel like
the context is is huge you know what I
mean imagine I can only imagine being a
lieutenant of a person who uh of a a
department that couldn't catch this guy
oh yeah that's the thing that got so
much backlash from yeah so you're also
dealing with that stress so even if he's
a lieutenant over his buddies that are
getting backlash from like Nationwide
media Nationwide and probably an entire
like diaspora of like a culture that's
like you know like you guys didn't
[ __ ] say this this ethnic group like
you know oh right right exactly yeah so
it's like that must have been years of
stress too because they didn't catch
this dude for a long time do you think
like they have that moral responsibility
do you think your father was carrying
that kind of weight for his Department I
mean probably
that sucks yeah yeah that was Heavy
that's heaviest like I said there was
just so much [ __ ] going on back then
though you just got to keep going yeah
terrible crimes happening at the same
time just because of the state of where
Milwaukee was in
um you know it just happens they slipped
up on a huge serial killer that's true
because if you go into work and then
you're dealing with like 10 different
gangs that are going through war and
then you have a serial killer and then
you have a bank robber and then you have
all these like rape cases and all these
domestic violence cases and he just go
go to work and you're just like how does
this city operate with all this [ __ ]
crime I bet that's how all major cities
are because if you look at the city
stats even within La these smaller
cities every year there's a murder every
year there's like someone getting like
home invasion whatever just look at your
Police Department for your small little
like area it's crazy it might even be a
murder a week even yeah I mean there's a
lot of stuff going on and Justice Just
as you I would imagine if there was like
serial killers is probably also like
serial detectives that are also like
mentally in a just different wavelength
and frequency of like the way that like
civilians that are detectives no the
idea of like imagine like a detective
right who is working on a case in like
that [ __ ] cake like Sherlock Holmes
yeah for like years though like maybe
they can't [ __ ] close this case
they're trying to search for one guy but
they get like really tunnel vision yeah
yeah like a Zodiac Killer exactly I can
also Imagine The the other side almost
that anti-hero kind of like narrative
right yeah and imagine just [ __ ]
literally trying to capture one of the
most notorious serial killers in history
but they just didn't know he was a
serial killer until they got him right
the head and then there's all the
evidence you know
oblivious to the darkness yeah cause
people were really upset about that kid
even though this is why I don't
understand how they could let it go but
that kid had a hole in his head because
he was trying to give him a lobotomy to
become a zombie I don't know how they
didn't see it but you know Cops show up
there's a bunch of there's like
shootings there's people down happening
in the city all the time and then they
see like these drunk kids on the side of
the street you know they just let it go
big mistake but you know their priority
the police department was like you know
go after the big stuff they just didn't
know it yet obviously they took action
when they figured out what was going on
what's the major industry of Milwaukee
because it sounds like a [ __ ] it
sounds like a beer there's a beer
factory isn't that the tools dude
Milwaukee's known for beer for sure and
lobotomy so everyone works at the beer
there's a ton of breweries down there
um because remember Wisconsin's Dairy
like Milwaukee brewed and then they they
there's a Coors Light or something it's
like a pride or Wisconsin cheese yeah
our baseball team's the Brewers oh yeah
so a lot of beer and then a lot of dairy
Dahmer was alcoholic I've seen
connection tbrs connection did your dad
ever tell you um that he didn't want you
to be a cop or that he wanted you to be
a cop dude you think I was ever going to
be a cop believe in yourself I've seen
you play a cop maybe he wanted you to be
one did he ever want you to be one yeah
stay in the family business I don't
think so I think like could have been a
brewer I mean he he saw a lot of stuff
happen I don't it wasn't pushed on um
any of his kids to become cops
um do you think he was like a dancer
yeah dancer why you're disappointed you
can't arrest anyone as a dancer yeah
yeah you can't even do a citizen's
arrest as a dancer of course we're
ending a Dahmer video with Dancers just
[ __ ] girls
citizens dancers are athletes Anthony
yeah shut up oh you got practice to
Anthony this is large this is large
there's a lot but they put medium I got
a 10 piece chicken nuggets give this to
me thank you chicken nuggets oh look at
all this stuff we got chicken nuggies
y'all
[Applause]
oh thank you man you got a large Diet
Coke
thank you
what's that I've got to fight with the
pillow and my neck's off tight it's been
time for two minutes to fight with a
pillow oh shots
oh [ __ ] we don't got straws we got
there's straws there's a straw right
here McDonald's
I ordered straws you gotta have the
McDonald's straw too because it's bigger
it's thicker what else
we got sauces
Nick Nick catch it where's Anthony this
was waiting for his food to get older oh
[ __ ] wait is this my McDouble who got a
McDouble I got a McDouble I got one
without cheese yo why is Anthony waiting
for his food to get older I don't know
yay oh I I didn't know wait oh wait I
didn't even get a drink I didn't even
get a drink here I got a Coke
where's my Buffalo one
who took my buffalo sauce all right oh
what do you get and you guys need
ketchup you got Ranch yeah oh [ __ ] I
don't think they gave us rash I got one
I got one I got him yo we got like 10
pies here
whose Coke is this
well there's yours Hey where's the
McFlurry all right what's that one then
this is the other this is Anthony leaves
they forgot the McFlurries dude I don't
know I put it in the freezer already
that's how fast I am there's two of them
that's smart
there's two there was two damn bro I did
oh there's two of them yeah oh yeah good
executive decision what about the pie
what about the parts
wait what sauces did you guys get I got
barbecue I got mine
spies
I think these are somebody's called
apple pies or pumpkin no there's two of
them are pumpkin no but then they didn't
give you guys pumpkin they gave you four
apple pies I'm recording this by the way
all right hey we have napkins here I
don't know
pumpkin pie there's a bunch of napkins
right there can you hook me up with some
of those napkins somebody oh this is a
pumpkin pie yes
all right guys you're welcome here you
guys see you're welcome I didn't get to
see you this time all right thank you
isn't it nice that I changed the plans
Isn't it nice you dropped them oh no you
gotta eat it
yo the fries we saved but
you gotta eat them fresh right away
okay then they didn't add ketchup
because they never they [ __ ] do this
all the time now they never add ketchup
even when you ask I was a [ __ ]
McDonald's you better change your [ __ ]
because we love you
[ __ ]
the you you do this because you're cheap
bastards now you don't want to add
ketchup but it doesn't feel like a
complete meal unless you put ketchup in
the bag you always have to ask oh can I
get a few ketchups every time
they don't do that anymore and it's not
just this McDonald's how do you like a
Double Quarter Pounder it's really
really beefy
I forgot how beef it is oh yeah because
I usually just eat Big Macs no it's
beefy that's why I like it but then with
Mac sauce is better but Mayo's pretty
good what
what did the slides say oh wait
yeah yeah nice cheers
it'd be fun to be like all right Steve
sent this in and then get him on the
phone and have him like do some on the
spot correspondence
so see we have Steve on the field he's
just at home reporting himself
we'll do that I should do that next time
because I got this
I got these
I get this there's a double hello hello
hello
I wish I had something cool to say like
yeah
hello hello
so guys an Asian man walks into a bar
he loves it has no contact so he walks
into a bar he sits down he's by himself
and the bartender comes up and he has
this really cool little box
um and he goes hey man uh you want to
see what's in my box and the guy's like
sure why not he opens the box and it's
so magical there's this little man just
playing the piano Beethoven Mozart the
most beautiful music he's ever heard in
his life he closes the Box the guy
that's at the bar he's like yo man like
I gotta I gotta know how you did that
um
you got to tell me and he's like okay
um you have to go to the alley there's a
genie out there you can ask him for
anything that you want and the guy's
like sick man
um 100 so he goes into the alley and
there's a genie there's a genie standing
there and the genie is like you can have
one wish anything you want and the guy's
like he's really struggling struggling
right now that's why he's at the bar you
know he's having a Don moment struggling
financially so he goes to the genie he's
like I want a million bucks right now
um you know it would change my life
million bucks that's all I need the
genie is like poof got you man so he
goes back into the bar
and it's filled with a million ducks and
he's pissed and he goes to the bartender
he's like what the [ __ ] man
um I asked for a million bucks and
there's a million Ducks here and the
bartender goes you think I asked for a
12-inch pianist
it's because he's Chinese he has a bad
accident
[Laughter]